uh hello and welcome to this evening's
we can be meeting with planning and
development management committee
and just to introduce myself my name's
adrian williams and i serve as the
committee
chair also present on this call of the
committee vice chair councillor ben
hartley
officers from the council's planning
service legal and democratic service
local highway authority as well as the
elected councillors who make up the
voting members of the committee
and before we continue i should just
advise everybody's information that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
to these new microphones to minimize
background noise
if you wish to speak on an item use the
chat facility to notify me and then wait
until you're invited to speak
um we did have um declarations of
interest recorded
at the last meeting however i think as
it's reconvened if we can just
um we can well confirm again if any
members have
uh an interest to declare officers yeah
uh me cheer um i think i declared it
last meeting
uh number 83 why clay covenew um
i've had no involvement in that
application but it does back onto my
home
so i think you could argue that i have
an interest in it so i won't participate
in the discussion or vote on this this
item and i'll stay out of it
thank you councillor um determine if i
could declare an interest please
in the application at um 208 to 210 most
lane
uh i live in the vicinity i'd also like
to confirm i that i played no part
in the preparation of the report before
the members this evening thank you
and i'll take no part in the in the
meeting at that point
thank you mrs coley um i should just
know that the committee is core
we were expecting to be joined by um
councillor akanola who is
substituting for councillor um thomas
and also by councillor holden who is
substituting for
councillor bigby i don't know them on
the call yet um hopefully they will join
us but as reporter i suggest that we
move
to um the applications that are left to
consider
the first application we'll turn to is
manny halal meat and vegetable shop
which is on page 230 of your committee
report
before we proceed to representations or
the discussion it's going to be
introduced by ms milner
thank you chair okay i'm just gonna
share the presentation
with you
okay you should be able to can you
you're able to see this presentation
yeah we can yeah thank you so the first
application for you this evening relates
to 208 to 210
moss lane in hale and it's a corner unit
um
and the application is before you
because a planning officer has declared
an interest
the application released the ground
floor units at 208 and 210 muslim which
along with 206 um
are a parade of three commercial units
and the end unit number 210 is currently
occupied
by a vegetable store and grocery store
at ground floor of residential above the
middle unit
um is was used as a cafe
um again with residential above and so
office space above and the
end unit 206 is currently used as a
physiotherapist
practice um at ground floor with
residential above
and on the corner um 210 on the corner
is on the corner with
clarence road planning permission is
sought for the direction of a front
and side extension so this is the
existing elevations you're seeing
on your screen and then the application
is for this
front extension here and it projects
forward off the front building line and
to the side
and also for a staircase to the rear
this is part
of um works to amalgamate units
208 and 210 at ground floor to be one
large unit
so here are the elevations so as you can
see um i don't know if you can see my
cursor but you have
a section here that would project
forward with a flat roof
and glazed windows and a central door
and at the back you have
a staircase leading up to the first
floor
and the staircase would be adjacent to
the back of
208 and 206 the key issues here
are design and impact on america's
amenity as well as highway safety
and there was an issue noted in your
report about um
a potential issue with the local highway
party raising an objection due to land
ownership
they have confirmed that following
amendments that the application no
longer proposes to
encroach on the public footpath in terms
of their land ownership so they raised
no objection
and however that was not part of
officers
consideration in their recommendation so
this is the unit as existing
and on the corner they wish to
amalgamate with the central unit and
project forward and to the side and
that's just
from a distance and then looking down
clarence road
and a unit to the side and at the back
and this is
where you see the flue approximately
around there where you'd have the
staircase
officers considered that because of the
the design that would project forward of
the
established building line on moss lane
and the
design of the extension with a flat roof
and the fenestration in terms of the
windows at doors
covered with the side extension would be
um
detrimental to the appearance of the
street scene in character
and also the rear staircase due to its
scale would also be
detrimental to the character of the
property but also fundamentally the
staircase at the back would be in close
proximity
to the back of 206 and 208 and would
potentially cause significant
overlooking from the platform of the
staircase into the rear
206 therefore officers consider
that due to concerns over design and
impact amenity that the applications
should be refused
and for the with the reasons for refusal
set out
in the report relating to design and
amenity thank you
thank you ms mona i understand there's
one speaker to this application
um speaking in favor of car
good evening thank you for allowing me
to speak um
confirm you've got three minutes to
speak um and if you do run over a little
bit i'll just politely request that you
have upset okay
yeah that's fine thank you very much
indeed so as the architect of mr jars
emmet i'm here to put forward the views
of my client
the building is used as meat and fruits
and vegetable retail shop
as mentioned the premises occupy the
corner plot to 210 moss lane and is
typical of local and national terrace
properties having a corner shop within a
residential area
my client has been at the current
address for the past seven years and has
20-year lease agreement with the
landlord
mr ajaz emma has been a devoted
shopkeeper and has recently moved with
his family by close to be close to the
shop address
this is his livelihood and wishes to
make improvement for his employees his
customers
and more importantly to the community
since he has been at the property he has
struggled with his employers carrying
boxes of fruit and vegetable in and out
of the shop due to spatial constraints
customers are also restricted with space
and struggle to shop easily and
conveniently
with the covert 19 restrictions
implemented this has become a further
significant constraint and more
challenging
the proposal for the extension is to
generate additional working space but
more importantly to create a neater
environment for the customers and
employees
with further capacity to provide for the
local community
the business is having to display items
outside the shop in the open environment
and this creates an untidy shop front
when the weather is bad customers
struggle to shop since there is no
shelter or protection from the outside
the extension will make shopping a more
pleasurable and comfortable experience
for the customers
and workers and remove the need to
display goods external from the building
the previous proposal encroached on the
adopted highway
with constant communication with
planning officer the proposal has now
been amended
determined that no part of the extension
will be on the adopted highway land
subsequently the elevations have also
been amended to incorporate
incorporate a replica of the existing
shop front to create more vernacular
elevation
to the street scene it is not considered
that the proposal will
be detrimental to any of the surrounding
residential properties
the site is located with the
predominantly residential area is merely
extended into a single extension
to the shopkeeping with the local
established characteristics of the area
an existing shop front in keeping with a
local architecture
the proposed shop front will be in brick
matching to existing with new shop
signage the property next door to number
211
11 will be an extension creating back of
the house facilities for his employees
incorporating office and storage space
on the first
floor of the property the proposal will
be intended to
be constructed using traditional high
quality material to match the existing
appearance the proposal does not
anticipate creating additional traffic
this situation will be no different than
it is already with street parking
manny's meat and fruits vegetable shop
proposal
intention are to preserve and enhance
the carrots of the area and community
the proposed development will only
enhance the street scene create
an orderly and need to environment
providing a community facility that
provides a service to the community
since the planning application
submission he has only received
substantial support from customers and
residents
we only hope that this planning
application can be recommended for
approval
thank you
thank you mrs khan um since the
discussion i think counselor dr park for
you
indicated to ask a question uh yes thank
you
uh through you please my ask planning
officers
um would the proposed ex front extension
be cited so that the boxes that we
currently see in all the stories that we
see
in front of the property at the moment
would that be replaced
by the extension because at the moment
obviously a lot of space is taken up by
those storage boxes so
just be grateful if you could kind of
give a yardstick for how much the
forward and
the front elevator front extension would
um equate to in terms of those boxes
that they're currently thank you
yes um so the extension at the front
would project at most by
2.4 so looking at the photographs
i think that they certainly will take in
some of the boxes and but the boxes
aren't there by consent that
they're put there so it depends if
they're
you know it could technically take up um
the space at the front
and go to the slightly to the side um
adjacent to the entrance
um i can't really see the extension
isn't projecting out
at the entrance just outside into the
front but yes to the front it would
cover i think the space which we can see
on the photographs which
the boxes are at the moment however the
unit is also
amalgamating with next door so there
would be space
in the neighboring unit as well
i think councillor dr buddy did you want
to come back in here
yes i mean i i do remember this
application coming before committee a
number of years ago
and there have always been issues about
the kind of the with the boxes at the
front
and um clearly i mean i think they were
not meant to be there i do remember that
but i just wondered if that was
um something that kind of had been
overlooked because it's been that that
situation has persisted
uh for a number of years we've never
actually managed to get that space clear
and i've always felt that um it was
really distracting i mean i think one of
the reasons it was refused was because
of the
um it presented a really hazardous kind
of visual
image on the highway as you were it's a
busy it's a busy crossing going
going across the road and up the road so
it was it was really dangerous but those
boxes have been there and never been
removed so
i think it's really really important i
really i've realized that because i do
feel
that and therefore the the extension
wouldn't really be acceptable because
this that space shouldn't be taken up
anyway but even if even if it was
acceptable then there's the issue of the
overlooking
and um i think that's a reason that
would well for me anyway i don't think i
can support
um approval of the application because
clearly there is such a significant risk
of
overlooking from that staircase at the
back that even if the front was
acceptable which
i don't think it is either and then that
would be a significant
uh reason not to support it so i do
support officer's recommendation
reluctantly
uh because obviously everyone wants to
see businesses thrive and i totally
understand
the need to get more space but obviously
not not at the extent that
it damages acute visual um the
appearance of the street the immunity
for residents
and at least overlooking so i will
support officer's recommendation for
refusal
thank you chairman thank you councillor
dr bartley um
council accordingly um
thanks chair very similar to uh
councillor dr barclay
um happy to second her in in fact
my main my main concern is the
overlooking at the back the
um i actually looking at it i went over
to see this in the rain and um
i did actually like the extension and uh
i think it um the the at the front
but it's that back that really worries
me the staircase and
while that's in the planning i can't
support it
um so i'd happy happy to propose um
accepting the officer's report
thank you council accordingly and
councillor proctor
yeah thank you chair um on similar lines
really i mean when i
first looked at this application i was
kind of 50 50 really it was
i think it was looking like quite a um
subjective decision
on you know whether the visual
appearance of it was was good or bad
um i mean i can obviously see you know
the benefit for the applicant it would
create a lot of
um retail space for them you know help
their business
dramatically and i think i can i can see
the logic of it and
you know the plans are are quite good
um looking at the front it it is
i think i think it's okay um i don't
think it
it's great great um but it
it would be okay acceptable and the the
sticking point for me is the overlooking
aspect at the back
i think that's going to be quite
significant really
so um in view of that
um swayed towards agreeing with the
officer's decision on this to
reject the application keep you all in
that aspect of it
thank you jeff thank you councillor
councillor hartman
thank you chair um i'm of the same mind
yeah i think we should
uh support the officer's recommendation
to to refuse
permission i think the staircase at the
back is it's probably fairly
straightforward and other people have
covered that
um for me the the extensions at the
front and
and the side um they are they are
sort of overly dominant they do alter
the street scene it
they you know build out from the the
building line
both out of the front and and at the
side on on clarence road so it would
significantly change the street scene i
think uh and
affect the immunity to the area um the
the benefit
i suppose is that is that you avoid
having the the boxes on the pavement
possibly although mindful of what miss
milner said it you know
might not entirely avoid that so um
you know that that will be an advantage
that it might look a bit sort of tidier
um but i think in planning terms the you
know the adverse impact clearly
outweighs that that benefit
um i i went down to look at it as well
spent spent some time sort of looking
around all the different
um all the different elevations i
suppose and
you know i went on a sunday mornings in
the lunch time the shop was really busy
it
had a steady flow of customers so you
know
in terms of the trade it seems like a
you know a healthy business that that's
running and i think
the boxes outside aren't ideal but i
think there's a lot
less of an impact to those and obviously
that isn't a permanent
impact on the street scene and you know
i'm sure the
the owners could could do something to
sort of tidy that area up
if need be so yeah i think fairly
fairly clear in my mind that we should
um agree with the officer's
recommendation to
to refuse permission on this application
thank you chair
thank you council of harlem it is
interesting listening to other members
because
my bigger objection to the application
was actually um
on the basis of the extension to the
front of the property
and the fact that it would break up in
essence that the building line
and i think that's really quite
comprehensively covered in paragraphs
eight through ten of the report
um now there isn't anyone else looking
what indicating that they'd like to
speak in the chat i think that it's been
proposed by council accordingly
that we um accept officer recommendation
i'm happy to second that i think i don't
think councillor dr partly did propose
it because you think it was council
accordingly
um if there are any other members
looking to speak please please let it be
known but otherwise
we've discussed um all the aspects of
the application we can move to the room
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded that we accept officer
recommendation to refuse
permission for this application i'll
move through members as you appear on my
screen
um just asking how you intend to
customize counselor proctor
uh happy to agree with officer
recommendation to refuse thank you chair
thank you council councilman morgan
i agree with officer recommendation to
refuse chair
thank you councillor
recommendation to refuse thanks jen was
that agree
sorry yeah i agree with officer
recommendation
thank you uh councillor kirby
i'll vote to um go along with the
recommendation to refuse thank you
chairman
thank you council a minute
i'll support the officer's
recommendation to refuse thank you
thank you councillor
thank you chair support officer
recommendation to reviews thank you
thank you
council accordingly support officer's
recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor acting yes agree
the officer's recommendations to refuse
thank you and councillor dr barclay
i support officer recommendation to
refuse thank you chairman
thank you um councillor holden is now
with us for as he hasn't heard the full
debate
it is indicated he won't be casting a
vote i would be voting in line with
officer recommendation i make that
unanimous decision and
the application is refused
the next item for consideration is
83 white lake avenue which is on page
223 of the committee reports
um before we hear from speakers i
believe
that the application is going to be
introduced by ms milner i will leave the
meetings
thank you chair i'll just again share my
screen
this application is reported to the
planning committee because
more than six of objections have been
received contrary to the office of
recommendation
applications it comprises a two-story
semi-detached dwelling house located
located at the north estonia
western end of white lake avenue the
gardens of the application property and
the
joining property number 85 are of an
unusual layout with both extending
significantly
to the western side rather than directly
to the rear of the dwellings
and the common boundary between the two
properties splayed across the rear
elevation of the application property
as you can see on this
site location plan um on your screens
number 85 has a single story flat reef
extension adjacent to the boundary
the proposal has been amended to relate
solely to the direction of a single
story
rear side extension and a first floor
window
the original submission included a loft
conversion and a rear door
and balcony at roof level um as well as
running with the
of the entire property these elements
have now been admitted from the
application
and however a number of objections
related to those
elements are still on file and because
they've not been formally withdrawn
the proposed single story extension
would project westwards at an angle to
the existing property the extension
would be of a contemporary design
incorporating timber
black zinc cladding and a mono pitch
roots at different heights
the proposed development would create a
kitchen a dining room snug
and an outdoor timber framed dining area
so as you can see here and on the plans
and the extension's splayed off to the
west
and of an irregular angle and then
um here on the drawings as you can see
um
apologies it's not particularly bright
but as you can see it is
um a design there's a contemporary
design with timber cladding on the
exterior
the key issues are whether the amended
design would be acceptable
um considering the prevailing character
of the area
and whether there'd be any impacts on
amenity in regards to overshadowing
being overbearing or um a loss of
privacy
whilst it is of a contemporary design um
materials proposed are high quality it's
also significantly set back from the
front of the property and therefore the
impact on the street scene would be
extremely limited
and just looking at photographs as you
can see the property is tucked away and
therefore an extension to the side to
the rear
would have a minimal impact on the
street scene also
it's a ground floor extension only and
therefore the impact on the wide area in
terms of character and visual impact
again
is limited and and here in the
photographs you can see the irregular
value with the adjoining property
therefore
officers consider that um following the
amendments to admit the changes
to the to the roof that the single-story
extension would be of a high quality
addition to the existing property and
given its scale
and siting and proximity to the
neighboring properties we do not
consider it to cause um
negative impacts on the adjacent
occupiers therefore we do
recommend approval thank you chair
thank you ms mona um there is one
speaker to this item um
uh mr rainey a good evening
good evening three minutes to speak mr
fellaini and if you do run over a bit
i'll just
lightly ask you thank you no problem
thank you very much
good evening counselors thank you for
giving the time to speak this evening so
our planning application is to build a
single story rear extension which you've
seen
which has been designed to make the best
use of our internal layout for the
family of five that we have
given a connection to our garden which
does not currently exist
whilst also maintaining as much open
garden space as possible for our young
children
consideration has been given to
restricting the effects of an extension
to our neighbors
who have subs subsequently given us
explicit science consent to the size and
the location of the building that's both
neighbours at 85 and 81
excuse me the reason for this
application being called committee was
because the original scheme incorporated
the dorm roof extension
which some neighbors had objected to
this element of the design has already
stated that was removed from the
proposals
however when we were reconsulted by the
council with the neighbors that the
dormer extension that was not removed
from the original description of the
works therefore the objections were not
withdrawn
the planning officer as we recommended
that we grant the proposal therefore
this evening
i would hope to require your formal
approval from all of the committee many
thanks for your time
thank you mr delaney and jerome you
indicated like to open the discussion
i did go and visit this application um
and i i think once the the first floor
balcony and the dormer
have been removed from the from these
plans the objections do melt away really
and also the the reasons for refusing
such an application
or debating it really um i think
it's mainly policy compliant as well um
or fully policy compliant
um and it really comes down to the
design because i don't think you'll
really be able to see
the extension from from the highway so
there is no
impact on the street scene um and i i
think the designs
find myself and again it's always going
to be a sub subjective matter
but i don't think we've really got any
reason for refusal here
and i'm happy to propose that we accept
offer
officer recommendation to grant uh chair
thank you councillor and councillor
minis
thank you chair um i've i i also think
that the
the reasons to object have now gone i
think actually that the person has
the new plan uh goes uh works with the
plot
size and the the unusual sighting of the
plot
and because it's all tucked away and
because it's a first floor only
and you know sorry not first of all it's
a ground floor only not not
a second story on it i think it's
perfectly fine and it actually suits the
property quite well
um i'd be happy to second uh councillor
jerome's uh
did you propose to presume so yes happy
to second
um to grant applying permission thank
you very much
thank you councilman councillor dr
barkley
well thank you chairman yes i'm al also
very happy with the application i think
it's really really neat
extension and i just really wanted to
say i wanted to commend
mr delaney for working so hard with his
neighbors really it's not always the
case
uh planning that um we've heard that um
applicants work hard uh to make sure
that their neighbours are happy so
um i really do appreciate that i'm sure
we all do as a members of planning
committee
and very happy to support the officer's
recommendation thank you chair
thank you councillor dr barclay uh
absolutely echoed those sentiments
myself
um i think it's also welcome that the
applicant has taken on board some of the
feedback
that the planning department have
provided we don't always see that
that generally appears to be a view that
reasons for objection have largely been
um
addressed through the amended proposal
and i think i agree with that i mean i'm
looking through
the summary now and it says um
that the proposal might be out of
keeping with surrounding properties well
maybe but as i was looking at the plans
presented to us by ms milner they looked
to be of a good quality to me and i
think
actually it could enhance the local area
now
no one else has indicated in the chat
that they'd like to speak
i'll just give members a brief moment if
they did want to say
[Music]
no but it has been proposed and seconded
that we approved this
application in line with officer
recommendations so i'll just run through
members as you're now appearing on
my screen counselor morgan
thank you chad agree with officer
recommendation to approve
thank you councillor councillor jerome i
also agree with
the recommendation to approve thank you
councillor curry
approve please chairman thank you
councillor minis i'll agree with the
officer recommendation to grant thank
you
thank you councillor hartley thank you
chair agree with officer recommendation
to grant thank you
thank you councillor holden supports the
officer recommendation to grant thank
you
um council accordingly support officer's
recommendation to grant
and keep council of acting agree the
recommendations to grant
thank you and councillor dr barkley
support officer recommendation to grant
thank you
thank you and i will also be voting in
line with officer recommendation
then again to my mind that's a unanimous
decision the application has been
approved and
the next application for consideration
is for water mint y
which is on page 240 of the committee
report
and before we hear from speakers the
application is going to be introduced by
mr milner can i just check that kevin's
back
oh
is he
yeah you said shown on my screen now
hopefully that's okay
okay chair right i'm just going to share
the presentation
so the next application relates to
for ultimate way apologies i've
lost my yeah and so the application
relates to um
for water mint way and the application
is before members because we have
received more than six
objections contrary to officer
recommendation
the application site comprises a
three-storey detached dwelling house
located on the north side of watermidway
and residential street in altringham and
dwelling has an attached garage to the
east
side and rear respective planning
permission is
sought for the single-story rear
extension and front porch
and the plans in front of you on the
screen at the moment represent the
previous approval so an
application was granted for a front
porch and rear extension
however they've not been built in
accordance with the approved plans
and so a new application has been
submitted to regularize the development
on site
so this is the as pre as approved
development and this is
as built so the extension and
to the porch has increased in scale so
the width has increased and therefore
and the the although the the roof has
has changed because of the pitch
so that the scale of the extension is
larger
and to the rear the roof has also
changed from a pitch roof to a flat roof
so there you see these are the as
approved
and again apologies for the they're
quite light on my screen
and but you can see there is a pitch
roof um sleeping up towards the main
house
and at the front you have the porch and
at the front
the as built shows um
a larger porch and a flat roof and
however the
applicant has proposed because it's a
flat roof there's a parapet
which means that the brick is built up
around the edge they have proposed to
slightly reduce that
and and so there you see it just a
couple of brick horses removed
at the back um and this is because it is
retrospective we do have photographs as
as built so this is the porch to the
front and to the side as you can see
here and then this is the extension to
the rear so it's a flat roof
extension to the rear as viewed
so we have received a number of strong
objections to this on design grounds and
there are real concerns
that the design is not complementary to
the character of the wider area
that the flat roof would um be
detrimental
to the design of the estate so the key
issues are
design and and the impact it could
possibly have
on the amenity of the surrounding area
and
officers consider that yes this is a
large rear extension
and in terms of depth it has approved
whilst the overall
height hasn't increased the me
the kind of the medium height has
because it's all now one level
so it does appear as quite a large
structure however we
do consider that the materials are a
very good match to the existing property
and and that when viewed in the context
of the wider area yes
there are a number of pitched and sloped
roof extensions and therefore
is slightly different but flat roof
extensions and
are quite common therefore we do not
consider that
um it merits refusal therefore subject
to the conditions as set out in your
report we do recommend approval thank
you chair
thank you ms mona and that are two
speakers to this application um speaker
against
called it because are you with us yeah
yeah and you've got three minutes to
speak and if you do everyone i'll just
politely ask that you and
wrap up your remarks thank you thanks
for giving me the opportunity to speak
so i have considered the officers
recommendations
in relation to the application for the
retrospective
planning permission and unfortunately i
do not agree with the
same uh six neighbors in the mjt
vicinity have
objected to the retrospective
application the massive flat roof
extension has has used height of 3.6
meters
significantly more than 2.2 meters as
previously
approved this dominates the local area
and
is not in keeping with the other
monopitch extensions that have been
completed in the area
it has overbearing effect visually not
attractive and not sympathetic to the
area
this is going to set a bad precedence
for future extensions
photographs i believe have been
submitted to support this and i
the the panel to these place
none of the neighbors had objected to
the original plans
when neighbors realized that the
extension was not being built in
accordance to the original plans
all of them approached the owner with
some solutions but the owner failed to
respond
at that time the council was also made
aware of the breach of planning
permission but
the owner managed to complete the
construction to his desire
i would request that the retrospective
application
should be refused on the grounds as
mentioned however
if the committee feels that permission
should be granted with
officer's recommendation i will request
the committee to address the security
issue for six water mint way as well
the flat roof extension of four
watermelon
is nearly one meter higher and only six
ninety centimeters away from the
existing roof of six water mint way
where two bedrooms windows open
this makes it easy for the burglars to
access the bedrooms
windows during summer time can't be kept
open for situated reasons making the two
bedrooms defunct
it was discussed with the owner of the
four water mint way and he acknowledged
the issue and promised to make
arrangements to make it safe
after getting advice from the security
specialist but this never happened
thank you very much
thank you mr bakaya um i understand that
um
dr quattro has submitted a statement to
be read out
yes i'm here with all right wonderful
thank you
and similarly to the in speaking you've
got three minutes and dr closure and if
you do overwhelm i'll just politely ask
that you wrap up your room
okay um respected chair and members of
the committee thank you so much for
letting me represent myself
um as you've seen my name is dr adil
khadja and i'm a consultant in care of
the older people
we have five children two of which go to
university
um and visit us intermittently depending
on restrictions
the rest of them are much younger after
living in various rented properties for
eight years in trafford area
we were finally able to buy an ideal
property with a potential for extension
in november 2019
and got an application approved in the
next few months for a rare extension to
accommodate a larger kitchen
and a dining area much needed for the
cyber size of our family
during the course of construction
planning we realized there was a design
flaw
in the original plan and the roof had to
be changed from a lean to roof or
to an inaccessible flat roof
which this retrospective application is
for
we have went ahead with the construction
in july last year after the lockdown had
been lifted
and i had also recovered from kovid
the weather was ideal for foundations
and the exterior construction
it never occurred to us that the flat
roof could be used as a balcony or a
terrace
until a complaint from the neighbor led
to a call from the council
having said that there is no access to
the roof and there's no reason for us
to get onto a roof which can be a
massive risk of falls to
our three children and our indoor pet
this is the main complaint that has been
put on by the neighbors
to to appease the neighbors and on the
suggestion of the planning officer we
amended the plans to reduce the height
of the parapet
this will not only come at an extra cost
to my original budget
but also causes significant
inconvenience the whole kitchen
everything is is made the flooring and
all
myself and my wife we did hold a joint
meeting with all the neighbors
to la anxieties understand each other
and come to the solution
unfortunately it went in vain
our flat roof is not the only one in
stamford brook
um one of them has been approved on the
same street
water mint way as as it was um
and will be facing the street when it's
when the build is complete
wills overs is that is is is rear-facing
um is not at the front and is not
affecting the
street scene um
in the midst of dealing with this stress
of the pandemic as a front line and it
just working
worker looking after covet positive
patients i'm now having to deal with
this
i have suffered the disease and several
and seen several colleagues not only
being affected severely but also
die from it there's not a single day i
do wonder
uh if i'm next or my family gets it for
me
um as a family we're already stressed as
it is
we just want to get on with our lives
now coming to the security issues
i just want to
have the committee imagine a burglar
climbing over first passing my fence
and then climbing over my roof and then
jumping over from a flat roof to a lean
to roof
with with uh tiles risking falls
why would somebody do that you have over
one slightly you can wrap up your
contributions
thank you um i yeah that i'm finished um
i hope the committee will have a
sympathetic view on our application
thank you
thank you very much dr and
councillor hartley has put a comment in
in the chat just asking perhaps of some
clarification about um
the enforcement process and that would
be relied upon
upon this application being refused i
think it would be helpful for members
perhaps to just understand that because
it's not often that we get much
restrictive
um permissions being requested thank you
thank you chair and
so i think what we have to bear in mind
is there is
an existing approval on this site and
therefore that is taken as the baseline
so even if the application was um
refused we would have to consider the
the increased harm and the expedience to
take any further action
and bearing in mind we couldn't ask for
a reduction and
or we couldn't seek to make any changes
below what's already been approved
and in terms of the height i think the
approved height was 3.4
the proposed height is 3.1 and so we'd
be looking to make that assessment in
terms of
um expediency to take action and
public interest and uh and
and whether you know we if we took it to
an enforcement notice
whether what the chances are as winning
appeal
and but yes we would we we can still
consider it
if it was refused it would go to our
enforcement team they would make their
own assessment and we would look at the
next steps
however to be clear any next step would
never see a reduction below what was
approved
and that is the baseline and so you can
kind of you know can we do something to
find a middle ground
and however officers are proposing you
know but that we do not
consider that at this stage that that's
necessary
um so there may be limited scope but we
would
look into this further purely from an
enforcement-minded point of view
that's wonderful thank you other members
have indicated they'd like to speak but
councillor hartley is you've raised the
question i'm just wondering if you had
anything you wanted
just to put back to ms mona
um no not as such chair that that advice
it is is really helpful and understand
that we couldn't obviously
do anything um below what's
what's what's been approved i i mean i
suppose that
those are my comments on the application
i don't know if you want to take on the
speaker's first chair and come back to
me but my comments on the application
are
around um you know are around what was
actually being built beyond
the you know the extant planning
permission
and i i'll go to councillor dr bartley
and we'll turn to you comes out they
think
okay thank you chairman um i do
understand the neighbor's objections i
mean it's always really disappointing
and
also almost bewildering how things
manage to get built
not according to plans given that you
know these are
very very detailed things i can
understand neighbours being upset about
things with particularly when
a sloping roof turns into a flat roof
and things look bigger
and this is really disappointing but if
we were to refuse the application we'd
actually be
asking for these structures to be
partially demolished to bring them back
down to the
agreed um authorized heights and i think
that's really exceedingly harsh
given that um planning officers are
really happy with the
development as it is i mean obviously
we're never pleased to have to do
retrospective applications but
there is no harm caused by these um
increased heights i mean
it's not good that they have been
developed to this size but there's no
actual harm
it says there's no undue harm to the
character and the appearance of the
dwelling the street scene
so with all that in mind and given that
it would be exceedingly harsh
to ask for anything else i'm really
happy to support officers
recommendation to approve thank you
chairman
thank you councillor talked about the um
councillor minis
thank you chair um i so there's
obviously two parts of this is there's
support which i think the porch actually
although it's a little bit bigger i
don't think is you know overbearing i
don't think it causes a massive problem
the i have a real problem with the back
extension i do
um it's bigger it's taller because it's
not got um
the sloped roof it's got the flat roof
it it does look overbearing you look at
the pictures and it does look a bit of
an eyesore to be honest
and that's the way i see it and if you
look at the surrounding area they don't
it doesn't quite
fit with the rest of it and i appreciate
that
the the you know the applicant has
already built it and everything and it's
a
total pain to have to undo something but
then
why you know you had an application that
was approved
you then gone bigger taller changed the
pitch of the roof
i'm not quite sure what you expect to
happen with your neighbours your
neighbors are not going to be happy
and i understand you may want a slightly
bigger room
you know i get that but that's not what
was approved
and i'm afraid you know these obviously
the neighbors were
were fine with the original application
which got approved and they
there was no problem but they obviously
do feel
quite like this is really an eyesore is
that they're saying about obviously the
um you know safety implications and
things
but i i think just the the visual
immediacy to be honest
i'm going i don't i i you know i don't
think it's acceptable to
let to make the neighbors put up with
that
when it was never approved in the first
place
and that was never the deal you know at
the beginning so
i'm going to be i'm afraid i'm going to
be proposing that we actually refuse
this application
thank you very much chair
thank you councilman councillor hartley
uh thank you chair i i have a you know i
have similar
sentiments to to council le minis uh to
be honest
although i probably come down to
concluding that
that we agree with the officer
recommendation to grant
i mean the reason i ask for the advice
about about the enforcement
process is it it's
it's it's unusual although we have seen
applications
like this before where someone applies
for retrospective planning permission
for
what's uh for what's actually being
built and
and of course residents can do that that
that is a legitimate thing
to do but i think what um
you know what really concerns me about
this sort of application and the other
ones we
we've seen is that what what has
actually been built is such a departure
from what is in the plans and what is in
the the planning permission
um that it just seems to disregard the
planning process
so you know if you build a flight roof
instead of a pitched roof
it you know it's not just a question of
you've built it a few centimeters out
it's a deliberate design
choice to build something that is not in
accordance with the planning permission
you've obtained
um similarly with the front porch i
think you know it's significantly wider
than
than the subject of the application i
don't i don't think that's you know a
mistake in
in the measurements so you know what
what concerns with this application and
others we've seen
is where residents householders are
making a deliberate choice to
build something that doesn't accord with
the planning permission that they've got
and
and i think where they do that we should
be quite clear they do that at risk
of having enforcement action taken and
that we
we could ask them to put put those
extensions back to
what has actually been approved and and
i think
the more we see this practice the more
likely it is we'll see an application
where i think the committee may need to
make that stand and where the impact
on uh on neighbours and residents is
overbearing so that we should
we should take that option um so i mean
having having said having said that
about
enforcement i i do think the extensions
are out of place i think the the front
porch looks too wide it does look out of
proportion
um there aren't similar porches along
that road
or on that bit of the estate the rear
extension
uh again looks out of place because um
certainly the houses in that area around
the back of um
watson way the ones that i've got
extensions have all got i've all got
pitch roofs so i didn't i didn't see
another one with a with a flat roof
um in in that area so i do think both of
the
alterations are out of place um
the i mean have i said that the build
quality it looks good the brick
work does blend they've blended the
brick sort of patterning as well
sort of half up the walls um
i was quite struck by what mr bakaya
said actually about the security risk of
a
of a flat roof i'm i'm not sure what
what we can do about that
it would be good if we could do
something about that by way of a
condition that
some measure is taken to to mitigate
that risk
uh i say that because i know that on
stanford brook on the estate
certainly a couple of years ago there
was a big concern amongst residents
about
about burglaries of properties in the
area so it's it's not a
it's not an unreasonable anxiety to have
but you know the only thing i can think
of is that you
you know you built some sort of barrier
or fencing between the two ruse and and
that would probably be unsightly but
if anyone um has any suggestions about
how we could
mitigate that concern i think that is
something we should
we should consider i mean overall i
think
whilst the alterations do look out of
place
i don't think they have such a
significant
detrimental impact on the street scene
that we should
go down the road of refusing permission
and and then required the disruption of
alterations being made to bring them
back down to
what was approved in the original
application so um
i have to say very reluctantly i i think
the officer recommendation
to to grant um is probably right but i
say that reluctance because i don't like
this trend of
of residents building something which is
clearly different to what's been
approved
thank you chair thank you and
council hartley ms mona you've indicated
that you
perhaps have some qualification about um
retrospective applications
yes sure it was just to provide members
with a bit of reassurance we do
have a um an enforcement team
um embedded within the development
management department and
they are very active and
you know whilst um members see a limited
number of retrospective cases before
them
whilst the application has been built we
do still assess it against policy
and where we have applications that come
back to us which haven't been built
in accordance with um plans we still do
make that assessment and where necessary
we do
um seek to take enforcement action and
whether that be removal
in totality or amendments to a scheme to
make it acceptable so
um just a bit of reassurance that we're
not almost um
passing this because it's retrospective
it has still been assessed
and and just just a bit of reassurance
on that point you know our enforcement
team
are very active on on these points um
and also with regards to security
if you wouldn't mind just me picking
that up um raised by councillor hartley
i i fully appreciate their concerns
however i feel that
that is string slightly beyond what we'd
be looking at and i think any measures
to
to make a roof secure um you know
you're probably looking at you know
measures that might might
if it was a physical barrier would then
have visual impacts themselves
and and and i wouldn't really want to
encourage that we would be asking for
further
um height or feather barriers on that um
boundary because that one itself would
have an impact um
and in terms of security yes there may
be a risk but there was
you know that that would pertain to any
property with any extension
and or any platform that allows for
access
um into windows so i would just express
caution on that point
thank you thank you thank you for
picking up that
issue of um the security implications of
the flat roof in the location that it is
because council hartley is correct
i had a miserable election campaign in
uh
broad heath ward some years ago and that
that estate was targeted by burglary
um efforts great manchester police are
very clear about that
um i did just want to i think you
touched on this miss milner
um in your remarks my reading
of um the the summary and conclusion of
the and the report itself is that
the application before this is
essentially
um policy complaining have i understood
that correctly
i'm just wondering in terms of yes in
terms of
what we'd be looking at in in depth in
physical um
dimensions there is no reason why we we
would recommend refusal because the
dimensions in terms of its projection
past the neighbor
don't give rise to concerns the neighbor
has an extension
um as you would have seen from the
photographs so in that regards it's
policy compliant in terms of the design
grounds
we make that assessment on character and
so it's not as
um um you know it's not as
hard and fast in terms of numbers you
know it's not you know a debt for a
height that make the character
acceptable it's more the the form
and the scale and the the overall design
character
and and i i do understand um so yes to
answer your question yes in terms of its
dimensions it's policy compliant in
terms of amenity
in terms of design we do consider that
it would be compliant because of the
the form it's taken and and the
materiality we feel that on balance it
is acceptable
and so that would be our conclusion
thank you uh very
difficult application i suppose i didn't
i i i visited this site and
you know it's not to my taste but if
it's policy complying you know it not
being to my personal taste is certainly
neither here nor there is
um counselor morgan you indicated early
that you'd like to make comment
thank you chair um and we probably share
something on uh
fighting the broad thought um in our
past um
and uh certainly i know again i also
know um
this state very well um the issues that
this
they have um i'm i'm gonna kind of agree
with
both council of minnesotan councils are
hartley and and the
in the summation of i find this
incredibly frustrating and this is
not just a slight error in terms of the
plans this is completely disregarding
some of the the core parts the plan um
and it's probably a side of me that if
we had complete control
i would want to in these sort of cases
just nobody has to start again
but you look at the plans and yeah i'm
not that keen on them but i don't see
any reason that if this hadn't come in
front of us
originally that i would necessarily be
voting against them so
i think i'm going to be supporting
office of recommendations but i do want
to put a record i really do find is
really really frustrating
and the fact that we're having to waste
officer time as well which is very
valuable
um having to do this i think is really
frustrating and
i can't understand the frustrations from
the neighbours thank you
thank you um councillor morgan council
of acting
thank you chair um i i think i'm going
to agree with other
other speakers um it really does annoy
me
when um you know
people will actually build uh to to
something that is not
been given permission for and
and i think as it's just been said
this is not a slight error you know
they've known
what what they are doing um and
i i i do actually think that
um you know in terms of the design
character
he to me it is over overbearing and
uh and shouldn't have been built in in
in that way
um i i don't have such a the same
sort of sense in terms of the porch
um but but i i i do with
with the extension i think it's um you
know
it's a bad design in my in in my view
however having said that i i do
understand
what what our officers are actually
saying and
um whether you know um
this would go to appeal and it would
probably be accepted on
on appeal um you know i
i think that we have to consider that
um but but it's with
with a heavy heart really that i would
actually vote for this because it's not
uh
i think it also gives a you know
a bad impression in terms of the
planning
itself if people build you know not to
the specification that have been given
permission
but i do understand the arguments that
our officers
have given to us so i think i'll be
supporting the recommendation but it's
with a heavy heart
[Music]
thank you counselor and no one else is
indicating a president that they'd like
to speak as i
um have noted it i think the application
has been
proposed that we accept officer
recommendation by councillor dr bartley
and there's been a counter proposal that
we refused by council the minutes
um is there anyone else looking to speak
or to
second either those proposals
i mean i will second um councillor dr
barclay's proposal
on the basis that um officers
have said that the application that's
before this is largely
policy compliant and that there is the
extent
permission as well um
i will extend to members a final
opportunity if anybody just wants to
speak if you can just indicate
counselor direct
thank you sitting back on this one and
listening to the arguments
many of which i agree with and
this this is a really tricky decision
to make and i wonder if the current
situation of the building will put in as
an application
now whether the planning department
would ask for
moderations and and differences to be
made to it
um obviously that's a a question i i
can't answer
and i think um helen milner
has probably answered that question
already but i think i'd
i will be um seconding uh councillor
minis
um just because
i think they have gone too far um my my
mind is telling me that um
i should refuse this application my
heart is kind of agreeing with
the proposal to accept the
recommendation
uh but um i'm going to go with my my
head rather than my heart on this one i
think
um or have i got that the wrong way
around
but anyway anyway i'm going to support
councillor minis uh
and second her proposal thanks chair
thank you
councillor jerome um there's now been
a proposal um that we approve and a
proposal that we refuse both of which
have been seconded before we move to a
vote um
i would extend again the opportunity to
speak to any member but i think
i should also express that we need to
articulate reasons for refusal and
now i think i'm trying to
summarize the contributions others have
made
i think that that issue was largely the
pitch roof
on the extension to the rear of the
property
um is there anything else that other
members wish to
yeah it's effectively the flat roof the
design of that part because obviously
the dimensions are policy compliant but
the
the um the way it's been the design that
i don't think
fits with the area um that's my
uh you know and you look at it and it
looks does look like an eyesore
to be honest and it's not an it's not
like oh we accidentally
did it that size and accidentally put
that roof on it it's not accidental
um it's not just a brick is whatever
size the brick is and
therefore to brick it it landed up that
size it's
clearly you know to do a pitched roof
you build it differently so this is an
intentional thing and i don't think it's
actually acceptable
i think personally if this actually came
in as an application before it was built
i don't think it would have been allowed
that the back bit particularly would
have been allowed
and i think the changes would have been
asked off the back part especially
the porch i'm not a great fan of but you
know i can see that
it's it's not the worst thing i think
that you know
i personally wouldn't have it like that
but that's personal preference the back
thing
i'm afraid i just can't i can't i think
in all
like you know i can't say that it's fair
to the neighbors
to have to have that it doesn't look
right
at all i don't know how that works in
look right
overbearing over dominant chair probably
yes and i think you can
see it from the street so um yeah the
street scene as well
which i think would that be a
residential immunity
perhaps i don't know if ms milner or mrs
coley can
um respond to that the reasons i've
heard that
relate to design overbearing over
dominant
and um residential meaning street scene
yeah i can i can formulate that into a
reason if that's what you'd want to hear
i mean what you're saying is the the
flat roof design of the rear extension
would conflict with the character of the
wider area
and be overbearing and over-dominant
within the street scene
and give rise to residential amenity
impacts through
visual intrusion and overbearingness
something along those lines
thank you that that's really helpful for
articulating that um
is there any other member machine to
speak
no okay well that we've had the um
proposal to refuse the application and
that has been seconded
uh when i moved to a vote uh on the
grounds that were articulated by ms
milner and i'll just run three members
as you appear on my screen um
tell us to let you that one i'm gonna
vote to review this application
thank you councillor councillor carey
i i don't support the refusal chair
thank you thank you councillor
councillor minis
voting to refuse the application thank
you
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you i'll vote against the motion
to refuse
thank you thank you councillor
councillor holden
i will also vote against the
motion to refuse much as i
tend to agree with some of the arguments
this building's there
it exists and uh changes would be
draconian
thank you counsellor um councillor
morgan
heavy heart i vote against um refusal
thank you councillor council proctor
yeah with a high degree of reservation
uh votes
against the refusal
thank you council accordingly uh vote
against the refusal chair
thank you council of acting yes with a
heavy heart i vote against
uh the motion to refuse thank you
councillor councillor dr barkley i don't
support refusal thank you chairman
thank you um i shall vote uh
against the motion to refuse and council
again i know you've joined us but
um i think as you joined meeting once
the item had already started um
i don't think your vote can be cast on
this item um
now i made that two votes in favor
of the motion to refuse and
nine votes against and that motion
is not passed uh there was also a
proposal that we vote
in to approve the application in line
with office of recommendation
and we'd now have to take that vote in
turn and i'll
move through members as you appear on my
screen and counselor jerome
i'm going to go against officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor counselor kathy
i'll vote to
go with the officer's recommendation
please chair
thank you uh councillor minis
i'm going to vote against the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you i'm councillor hartley
thank you chair yeah very reluctant i'll
vote uh in favor of the office officer
recommendation
uh to grant thank you thank you
councillor holden
excuse me i will also support the
officer's recommendation thank you
councillor proctor yep
support officer recommendation this is a
recommendation to
grant reservations thank you council
accordingly
support officer's recommendation chair
thank you
let's support the recommendations to
graham thank you
uh councilman morgan
support officer recommendation to grant
jeff thank you councillor dr barkley
support officer recommendation to grant
chairman thank you
again that's nine votes um to two
and that application is approved
um the last application for
consideration this evening is
18 albert place which is on page 248
of the committee report um i don't think
there were any speakers to this item but
it's going to be introduced by ms milner
before we turn to discussion
thank you chair and
presentation
okay so the last application relates to
18 albert place in ultringum
and this application is being reported
to the planning and development
management committee because
an officer of the council has an
interest in the application
the application site is a two-story
semi-detached dwelling house located on
the north east side of albert place a
corey suck
in a relatively new estate um
in ultrasound not far from the old
marketplace conservation area
and planning admission is sought for the
erection of a single-story extension to
the rear
and a very minor extension between 0.2
and 0.4
um meters deep
and the partial conversion of the garage
into level accommodation with external
alterations
so as you can see here the the
um currently to the side of the property
they would retain an element of the
garage which would
act more as storage space to the front
and the back would um
be amalgamated with the house and as a
whole an extension
it's it's just a very minor um increase
at ground floor to the rear as you can
see
um or maybe you can't overly clear but
it is a very small
projection at ground floor um
offices are satisfied that the
the main issues of design amenity and
highway safety officers
consider the design to be um highly
suitable for the the character of the
property
um and the scale is considerably minor
and we do not consider there to be any
residential amenity issues arising
from the development the concern is to
do
with parking and the loss of the garage
space for
parking um the application is before you
because the
development when built the estate did
have their permitted development rights
removed in relation to an extension at
the back and also
in terms of the change of use of the
garage and we do have an objection from
our
highway authority they have raised
concerns that the removal of the garage
for parking would result in a severe
impact on the highway
in terms of parking demand officers
consider that whilst
there would be a loss of one parking
space there would still be parking to
the front
of the the garage space and also there
is unrestricted parking on the road
um and therefore officers do not
consider that on balance there would be
sufficient reasons to refuse this
application
therefore we do propose we do propose
approval
and subject to the conditions as
outlined in your report which does
include
that the area to the front be retained
for parking
thank you chair thank you
uh ms milner are there any members i'm
looking to open the discussion on this
item
counselor hartley
thank you chair i'm i'm happy to propose
that we accept the officer
recommendation
uh i went down to have a look uh
never been to this estate before i
didn't didn't know it was there but um
that's the life of a planning committee
member you get to see parts of trafford
you might not otherwise do
um but yeah in terms of you know in
terms of the the street sheet and the
meaning
there's no impact there um because it's
you know an alteration to
to the garage space essentially um the
the parking
um standards are maximum standards and i
don't think that is a valid reason for
us to
refuse um the street i mean the streets
quite narrow
at that point it opens up a bit more at
the end of the cul-de-sac
um but it isn't restricted parking and
when i was there there was
already some parking on the road so um i
don't think the loss of that of that
parking space which
in reality is probably not used i know i
know a garage does count as parking
space but it's
it's often often not used so um
i'm happy to uh to propose that we
accept the officer's recommendation on
this one
thank you chair thank you
councilman thank you
chair um i i obviously think the
sorry again um i'll be voting
in favor of the application of likes a
second note did as a council heart
did you propose um yeah i'm happy to say
a second
uh the the that we put literally grant
promising sorry
very been a very long day um the
i would say that the although yes you
lose a car parking space
how many people actually use their
garage to park their car in it
and the the way you get into the garage
there on that for that
property is via the drive the driveway
so people are a lot more likely to just
park on the driveway and i think that's
an acceptable thing
and yes it may not be loads and loads of
parking but it is a cul-de-sac you can
park
um on the road so i'll be more than
happy to second that
and yes thank you very much thank you
councillor councillor proctor
uh yeah some alliance really there's no
real impact on
neighboring properties at all um
there's no negative impact on the street
scene so i don't think either of those
reasons to refuse uh the other thing i
always look at in these
sort of applications is the any
representations from neighbors and
there's been none
so i don't think that's the particular
concern locally about that
yes the car parking is a bit of an issue
but i think as council minister said
um lots of people don't parking in
garages anyway so i think it's it's not
a significant importance so i'd be
pretty happy to
approve this as well thank you chair
thank you
counselor and counselor holder you've
indicated you'd like to ask a question
that's sure yes in the paperwork
the section on relevant planning history
there's a reference to a planning
application
that was refused as recently as the 4th
of november last year
which looks quite similar to the one
that we're being asked to look at today
now i wasn't there for that meeting and
i just wondered if
any one on the committee or any of the
officers
remember why that was refused
whereas this one has been recommended
for
um would that have been refused under
delegated or
authority i don't think i can recall
that coming to committee
i can clarify this chair that
application was a certificate of lawful
development
and that was what i i referenced in the
introduction that this permitted
development for the scheme had been
removed
so they applied for permitted
development but they don't have rights
so it was a fused on purely the fact
that they don't have access to permitted
development rights and it would have
been a delegated decision
because it's a certificate wonderful
thank you
um thank you let anybody
else looking to speak i can't see anyone
have it indicated in the chat
i don't i mean it has been for posting
seconded now so we moved to the vote
um councillor gervais
i'll support the officer's
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you and councillor hartley thank
you chair support officer recommendation
to grant
thank you thank you councillor holden
support the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor proctor
support officer's recommendation to
grant thank you
councillor morgan support officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor acton agree
recommendations to grant
general thank you and councillor dr
barclay
support officer's recommendation to
grant thank you chairman thank you
and councillor i support officers
recommendation to grant thank you
council
and um i will also be voting in line
with office of recommendations
grant and made that result unanimous
and that application is approved
is there anything else that's left for
discussion i'm just
urgent business if any i've not received
any notifications
there's not um it just wouldn't mind
having
just saying a couple of things to
members about next month but we can
close the meeting for that
that's wonderful we can um terminate the
live stream possible